good morning John today is going to be a
good old-fashioned born video so I
decided to go outside so it would be a
little bit more interesting at least so
yeah I'm not gonna ride in the
helicopter with Bill Gates I'm not gonna
dump a bucket of ice water on my head
and I'm not you've got to do any sock
puppets I won't talk about what's going
on because there's a lot of stuff going
on and I kind of want to start a couple
of new projects the first project John
you are not allowed to know about but
everybody else should go to Lama John
calm because it's Jens birthday in a
couple of days and we're doing a little
something I'm gonna say whether
something is we're doing still some time
or two I wrote a song with Danny wine
cough the bassist from them abhi Giants
about a kidney that lived in four
different people you're interested in
making a music video for that song we
would love for you to do that and if you
do we might be able to provide you with
one of my kidneys say number three so
you know how I've been interested in
making adaptations of classic novels
into video blog series branching off
finally not doing Jane Austen we're
going to be doing Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein our version is Frankenstein
MD starring Victoria Frankenstein who is
not quite yet an MD I'm excited about
this one extra a lot because not only is
there comedy and drama and quirkiness
but there is also science scishow is
about to hit 2 million subscribers crash
course just hit 2 million subscribers
scishow space is about the head 200,000
subscribers so those things are going
very well thank you to everyone who
watches them I hope that you find them
enjoyable entertaining and educational I
do because he is laughing whatever thing
hi duck what are you doing I faked
through something and they're like yeah
that looks like the right motion relax
the little little Lucky's in the pond I
do I do I do
a chick of whack Webb we're getting very
close now I'm surprised by how close
you're getting this is kind of scary
there's more of you than there are of me
oh they're like you definitely don't
have any bread this is really
disappointing and I'll see you it okay
bye duck unexpected visitors
the last thing I want to talk about is
kind of weird John and I are always
looking at doing interesting things in
online video three things you need the
magic ingredients for making good online
video are good writing good on-camera
personality talent east of and good
editing so we thought it'd be cool to
create a little bit of a framework
within which people could stretch their
muscles in those three different places
for people who are interested in writing
we've got a little workshop system set
up over on Wattpad
I've also uploaded a video of me writing
a script it's really boring who are
interested in editing I've uploaded a
vlogbrothers video that is entirely
unedited if you want to stretch those
muscles you can download that video edit
that video and then share it and then
other people can critique you finally
for on-screen talent people I put a
couple of scripts linked in the
description and you can record those
things and edit yourself recording those
things I hope that this will be an
interesting fun collaborative thing for
people to work with each other and
critique each other and workshop their
their stuff there on my video stuff
sorry about the lens flare here rainbow
I love this world so I want other people
to be invited into it and working in it
and doing interesting things especially
people who care about it and know a lot
about it which I think includes a lot of
you but for the rest of you who don't
care about it in that stuff I got
something for you as well
[Music]
on the inside of my ear is bloated
Italian fire I challenge sigh show hosts
read rhymers Caitlin Hofmeister and that
guy for the ALS ice bucket challenge
John I'll see you on Tuesday I forgot a
thing what a surprise we're having a
back-to-school sale at dftba.com right
now 20% off all posters almost including
this brand new one it's a quote that I
said one time we are also for the first
time ever doing pens and notebooks and
folders that's it I think that's worse
and now you're dead fantastic